the guy was clearly a socialist he was
worse than a socialist he was a
Christian uh let's show you one more
from the late night hosts doing their
comedy because they were very nervous
that Jim Jordan Jim Jordan who by and
large is is a moderate he is painted as
a as a crazy far-right Winger and you
get how the the drill goes on that but
here's another late night quote unquote
comedian Steven colar going after uh Jim
Jordan and and largely the GOP fight for
the
speaker remember to get elected Jordan
or anyone else would need 2117 votes and
that feels nearly impossible in this
fractured caucus as Missouri's Mark
Alfred explained you could put Jesus
Christ up for speaker of the house and
he still wouldn't get 217 well that's
true the modern GOP would never vote for
Jesus I mean he was soft on Samaritans
and commanded everyone to sell their
possessions and give the money to the
poor the guy was clearly a socialist he
was worse than a socialist he was a
Christian cut your hair you hippie put
on some pants leave the sandals back at
your YK comrade what is the reverse of
Comedy if you is there a word for the
reverse of comedy tragedy tragedy I
guess that's worse that is like the
black hole of Comedy first off uh Jesus
Christ was not a socialist Jesus was
fighting the power when you're when
you're a socialist you're for
centralized power that actually is what
Jesus was fighting right whether it was
the money changers or it was the Roman
Empire so Jesus was certainly not a
socialist he wasn't a Christian right he
was a Jew Jes all right you got it
anyway do we even need to Conor can you
put up like a little image of what his
Studio looked like there the guy's
sitting there with One mic and a and
like a dirty ass sheet behind him the
guy's probably worth 50 million bucks
look what we've done here that's the
difference you see what I'm saying it's
the
[Music]
difference